et j'ai décidé dans un look pas possible
c'était énorme et après tu va nous
raconter c'est parce que tu t'es fait
virer par la star la plus grande star 30
c'est la star ça a été repris les
standards tout vous allez voir regarder
ce qu'elle a fait après vous allez voir
que j'avais fait un boss de ouf c'est
parti j'ai envie de m'enfermer pro-gym
enders
si tu as les poches vides il faut des
baigneurs
l'heure et la rigueur cette croisière
hello there c'est là à 2500 tender c'est
bien voici les petits l'odeur mari c'est
incroyable parce que c'est du djihad id
si t'as foutu dehors c'est la star des
stars c'est la star des stars
évidemment je n'ai pas reconnu parce que
je suis moins d'assurer je connais rien
tu croyais que c'était rené haby barma
c'est peut-être à 10 cette année
elle m'a les mauves beige book beach
c'est à dire vers la plage alors ça a
été repris par tous est ce qu on a
regardé un seul était repris même à
l'international à newsweek regard des
quizz marie simple non mais sérieux
c'est ouf
non mais il n'y a pas là il ya aussi
times il ya guardian il ya eu 6 mm
c'était il ya 26 bichot américain qui a
6 millions de téléspectateurs
non c'est un 3ème surtout à new york je
suis une très grosse star à mayol
d'ailleurs je m'en vais
[Applaudissements]
certains franchement ça c'est un rêve ça
oui ça bien le père excellent pour
shannen armes bien sûr d'ubs énorme pour
chanel c'est vrai pas besoin de
multiplier les images dans le monde
entier c'est fantastique et je fais moi
je pense que chanel est bon la remercie
devrait la remercier langage et bien sûr
et c'est vrai que c'est une pub
il me lance un prochain et ludivine
c'est une super pub pour chanel mais je
comprends que voilà a forcément la
sécurité ce duo-là live elle aurait pu
faire nos preuves dont elle avait peur
après moi je pense qu'il est très
content ça sera sa bosse de marketing
amado oui j'imagine tous les défilés à
venir le portrait robot la photographie
sans règle la sécu tu vas chercher sa
gueule partout c'est sûr ils avaient
d'ailleurs
tiffany c'est un beau coup franchement
bons coups de batte mais ce que je mets
dedans mais tu as fini en garde à vue
après il ya eu quelque chose tu vois on
connaît pas la presse si ça en fait le
plus haut encore ce genre de moment
c'est de pouvoir s'échapper et ils
étaient ils avaient tellement peur du
scandale que je commence à relais
laissez moi partir laissez moi partir ou
appeler à polisot steria me laissais ma
partie voilà enfin je dis laissez moi
partir ont appelé la police ils ont
appelé la police